>> HERE WE GO.
SO EXCITING.
I AM SO EXCITED.
LET ME GET MY NOTES TOGETHER.
SO MANY THINGS.
HAPPY FRIDAY, MY FRIDAY FRIENDS.
BEFORE I GET TO THE MONOLOGUE I
WANT TO SEND OUR THOUGHTS TO
THOSE CURRENTLY SUFFERING.
NOT HIM, I'M TALKING UP PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING THE WRATH OF
HURRICANE IAN NOT HURRICANE
GUTFELD.
WHAT A MESS I'VE LEFT BEHIND.
BRIAN WILLIAMS, I AM TAUNTING
KARMA, AREN'T I?
I AM.
I'VE BEEN FIRED MANY TIMES.
THEY CUT BRIAN WILLIAMS, HE GOT
DON LEMON, SAMANTHA BEE, AND NO
TREVOR.
I WOULD SAY SETH MEYERS IS NEXT
BUT I LIKE HER WORK.
SHE'S A KEEPER.
AS FOR ALL OF OUR FRIENDS DOWN
SOUTH IN ALL SERIOUSNESS DEALIN
WITH THE HURRICANE, OUR HEARTS
ARE WITH YOU.
ESPECIALLY WITH THIS GUY.
THERE HE IS.
IF THAT DOESN'T REFLECT THE
SPIRIT OF AMERICA, WHEN TIMES
GET TOUGH, I DON'T KNOW WHAT
DOES.
WE ARE WITH YOU, FLORIDA FLAG
GUY, WHEREVER YOU ENDED UP READ.
THIS WEEK FORMER PRESIDENT TRUM
SUGGESTED HE COULD MEET AT TEAM
TO BROKER PEACE BETWEEN UKRAINE
AND RUSSIA.
SOMEONE FINALLY MENTIONED PEACE.
HE DID IT ON HIS OWN APP WHERE
HE WROTE U.S. LEADERSHIP SHOULD
REMAIN COOL, CALM, AND DRY ON
THE SABOTAGE OF THE PIPELINES.
THIS IS A BIG EVENT THAT SHOULD
NOT ENTAIL A BIG SOLUTION.
THESE STRATEGIC, BE SMART.
GET A NEGOTIATING DEAL DONE NOW
BOTH SIDES NEEDED AND THEY
WANTED.
THE ENTIRE WORLD IS AT STAKE.
THREE QUESTION.
AFTER THAT.
THAT MEANS IT'S REAL.
OF COURSE BEING TRUMP HE HAD TO
REMIND EVERYBODY THAT THIS WAR
NEVER WOULD HAVE HAPPENED UNDER
HIS WATCH.
WE WILL NEVER KNOW IF THAT'S
TRUE OF COURSE, BUT WE KNOW YOU
CAN'T DO WORSE THAN HIS BUMBLIN
SUCCESSOR WHO ONLY STRIKES FEAR
IN PRETEENS WITH PONYTAILS.
SPEAKING OF, LET'S CHECK IN ON
HIM.
>> President Biden: , THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
>> THE RIGHT WAY TO GO.
IF THEY DIDN'T FIND HIM THREE
HOURS LATER ON AN INTERSTATE
CLUTCHING A TEDDY BEAR.
THIS WASN'T THE FIRST TIME TRUM
CALLED FOR PEACE AND NEGOTIATED
PEACE BETWEEN RUSSIA AND UKRAIN
IN APRIL HE SAID THEY SHOULD
NEGOTIATE NOW, NOT LATER WHEN
EVERYONE WILL BE DEAD.
EXCLAMATION POINT.
I IMAGINE IT IS HARD TO TALK TO
DEAD PEOPLE.
AS HARD AS BIDEN TRIES.
>> President Biden: JACKIE,
ARE YOU HERE?
>> THAT'S NORMAL.
BUT DESPITE HAVING NO DIPLOMATI
EXPERIENCE, TRUMP UNDERSTOOD
WORDS MOST RENTABLE VARIABLE.
THE LONGER IT GOES THE LIST THE
WORSE IT GETS IN LOSS OF HUMAN
LIFE AND TREASURE SO HE SAID
THIS.
>> President Trump: I HOPE
THAT YOU AND THE PRESIDENT WOUL
GET TOGETHER INSULT THE PROBLEM
THAT WOULD BE A TREMENDOUS
ACHIEVEMENT.
>> LOOK AT HIS FACE.
HE DOES NOT WANT TO HEAR THAT.
BUT THAT WAS THREE YEARS AGO.
NO ONE WANTED TO TAKE THAT
SERIOUSLY AT THE TIME BECAUSE
IT'S TRUMP, SO IS THIS RECENT
OFFER A CRAZY IDEA, A DESPERATE
IDEA, OR A BRILLIANT ONE?
IT COULD BE ALL THREE LIQUID I
SHAVED BILL HAMMERS BACK.
I JUST LEFT HIS INITIALS.
IT COULD MEAN LOTS OF THINGS.
THE FACT IS, WITH TRUMP, HIS
PENCHANT FOR DEALMAKING MAKES
HIM A BETTER DIPLOMAT THAN MOST.
IF YOU TABLE THE ANIMOSITIES AN
BRIDGES IN DEALS.
U.S. BOTH PARTIES WHAT THEY WAN
TO GET OUT OF IT.
EVERYONE NEEDS AN OFFRAMP
INCLUDING POLLUTED OR THERE
WASN'T AN END TO THE MOUNTAINS
OF DEBT.
IS IT CORRUPTION, SURE,
AUTHORITARIANISM, MAY BE A JESS
PERHAPS.
BUT YOU ARE CLOSE WITH THAT.
MY GUESS, IT IS EGO.
THE SUBJECT I'M AN EXPERT IN.
IT IS EGO THAT KEEPS PEOPLE IN
POWER FROM LISTENING TO THOSE
OTHER PEOPLE THAT THEY CAN'T
STAND YOU CAN HELP THEM.
MAY BE BECAUSE THEY AREN'T
DIPLOMATS WHERE THEY AREN'T IN
YOUR PARTY OR THEY ARE DONALD
TRUMP, BUT DONALD TRUMP HAS
PROVIDED THE WORLD WITH TWO HUE
SUCCESSES IT'S NOT THE
APPRENTICE OR HIS SIGNATURE
RIBEYE STEAKS, WHICH ARE
DELICIOUS, FIRST NORTH RIO
WITHOUT ANY DIPLOMATIC
EXPERIENCE HE OBLITERATED THE
THREAT LIKE THEY WERE HILLARY
CLINTON'S DREAMS HE WAS LAUGHED
AT, BUT HE DID IT AND NOW WHAT
WE HAVE IN HIS FACE AT PLACE AT
THE DMZ?
>> THE UNITED STATES SHARES OF
VERY IMPORTANT RELATIONSHIP WIT
INCHES THE ALLIANCE WITH THE
REPUBLIC OF NORTH KOREA AND IT
IS AN ALLIANCE THAT IS STRONG
AND ENDURING.
>> IT IS, IS THERE A 25TH
AMENDMENT FOR THE VICE PRESIDENT
?
OR AS SHE WOULD CALL IT AND THA
THERE IS THE ABRAHAM A COURT
ORCHESTRATED BY TRUMP SON-IN-LA
WHO HAD NO EXPERIENCE IN
DIPLOMACY ALTHOUGH HAVING TRUMP
AS A FATHER A LOT LOOKS BETTER
THAN ANYTHING ON ANTHONY RESUME.
IDIOTS THEM JUST MAKE IT LOOK
HARD.
BUT THEY TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
BROKERED A DEAL BETWEEN SWORN
ENEMIES.
IF THIS WERE A DEMOCRAT WHITE
HOUSE, THE STAFF WOULD HAVE
NOBEL PRIZES COMING OUT OF THEI
WHICH IS LESS PAINFUL THAN GOIN
IN.
I HEARD.
SO NOW YOU HAVE TRUMP OFFERING
TO HELP, AND I'M SURE THAT DREW
DISMISSIVE LAUGHTER FROM ALL TH
USELESS NOTHING KRATZ.
WHY SHOULD THEY BE LAUGHING?
IT'S NOT ANY FUNNIER THAN
DEMOCRATS BELIEVING THEY COULD
GET PREGNANT.
>> CAN BIOLOGICAL MEN BECOME
PREGNANT AND GIVE BIRTH?
>> SO MEN CAN HAVE PREGNANCIES,
ESPECIALLY TRANS TRENDS WHEN
PRITZKER GET YOUR SAYING OF FEE
BIOLOGICAL FEMALE WHO BECOMES A
MAN AS THERE FOR QUOTE MAN PAIR.
>> SOMEBODY WITH UTERUS MAY BE
HAVE THE CHANCE TO BECOME
PREGNANT WHETHER THEY ARE A
WOMAN OR A MAN.
>> I HAVE A FEELING AMERICA IS
ALMOST AT THE POINT OF SAYING
YEAH, WE'RE DONE.
AT LEAST WHAT TRUMP IS OFFERING
MAKES SENSE AND NO WONDER THEY
DON'T LIKE IT.
THEY NEVER SEE THAT STAFFORD
RIGHT NOW THEY HAVE NO WAY
FORWARD DIPLOMATICALLY IN ENDIN
THE WAR WE ARE PAYING FOR.
TRUMP MIGHT BE THE ONLY PERSON
TO PULL THIS ONE OFF, BUT
PERHAPS, WITH THE HELP OF
ANOTHER GUY.
YEAH, THAT GUY WHO ALSO SAW THE
FOLLY IN PICKING SIDES BETWEEN
THESE FEW COUNTRIES CAN YOU
IMAGINE THIS?
APPEASED TEAM THAT FEELS EXACTL
LIKE A BUDDY COP MOVIE.
ONE UNORTHODOX WILD MAN.
THAT IS A BRILLIANT IDEA.
FOR THIS TO HAPPEN, THEY WOULD
HAVE TO LOSE THEIR EGO.
THAT'S THE SAME THING I TELL
JESSE WATERS WHEN YOU KEEP SPRA
PAINTING HIS BALD SPOT.
FOR US THEMSELVES WHAT I BE OKA
WITH REAL PEACE IF TRUMP HAD A
ROLE?
IF YOU SAY NO, THEN THAT IS YOU
EGO TALKING AND YOU VALUE IT
MORE THAN HUMAN LIFE WHICH SADL
MAKES YOU ANOTHER USELESS
DIPLOMAT, LET'S GO TO JOY BEHAR
FOR COMMENT.
>> LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT GUESTS
SHE WROTE A CHILDREN'S BOOK
WHICH IS LIKE JEFFREY DAHMER
WRITING A COOKBOOK, FOX NEWS
ANCHOR JULIE BANDERAS.
HE HAS WRITTEN FOR SNL AND ELLEN
, AND SOMETIMES EVEN COMEDY
SHOWS.
TV WRITER AND PRODUCER ADAM END
HER.
YOU MAY RECOGNIZE HIM FROM
TRYING TO SQUEEGEE YOUR
WINDSHIELD, HOST OF FOX ACROSS
AMERICA, JAMIE VELA.
AND FINALLY, SHE ONCE TOLD THE
LITTLE ENGINE THAT COULD THAT H
COULDN'T.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR KAT TIMPF.
BY THE WAY, SPEAKING OF YOUR
BOOK, HOW WAS I DOING?
>> IT'S DOING GREAT.
>> SEALS REALLY HAVE PLUMMETED
AFTER I PROMOTED IT ON THE SHOW.
>> I THOUGHT I DROVE A LOT OF
TRAFFIC TO IT.
BECAUSE IT'S ACTUALLY ABOUT
BUILDING FORTS.
THANK YOU THOUGH.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK OF MY MY
IMPOSSIBLE DREAM?
BECAUSE IT IS AN IMPOSSIBLE
DREAM OF THESE TWO GUYS JOINING
TOGETHER LIKE SUPER FRIENDS THA
WE CURRENTLY ARE DON'T WANT US
OFFERED.
>> THINK THE IDEA OF TRUMP GOIN
BACK TO THE WHITE HOUSE WHILE
BIDEN IS THERE WOULD BE CLASSIC
FREIGHT IMAGINE THE NEWS
CONFERENCES BECAUSE HE WOULD
HAVE THEM DAILY WITH UPDATES AN
THEN BIDEN, I DO KNOW WHAT HE
WOULD DO, BUT I THINK IT'S
INTERESTING HOW THE WHOLE WORLD
CRITICIZED CRITICIZE THE
PRESIDENTS WHEN HE MET WITH
PYONGYANG AND THE TWO OF THEM
UNITED AND THEN YOU CHOOSE
KAMALA HARRIS TO BE THE ONE
DIPLOMATIC AND GOING OVER THERE
AND TELLING US ABOUT OUR
ALLIANCE WITH NORTH KOREA.
YES, AT THIS ADMINISTRATION HAS
SCREWED THIS UP.
>> SHE, YOU KNOW, IF I DID THAT
OR IF I SAW MYSELF DOING THAT I
WOULD SAY, XANAX.
TOO MUCH.
I AM TELLING YOU, I CAN READ
THAT JUST AS A MEDICAL EXPERT TO
, ONE OF THE MEDICAL EXPERTS
HERE AT FOX I WILL DIAGNOSE
ANYTHING YOU WANT AND MY VAN.
JIMMY.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT I NOTICED ABOU
BUDDY COP MOVIES, EVEN IF THEY
DON'T LIKE EACH OTHER THEY
ALWAYS WENT.
THEY CAN'T WORK TOGETHER BUT MA
BE TO, JUST ONE EACH TOGETHER.
ONE IS IF YOU GET SENT OVER
THERE HE GET THE FBI TO GET
THOSE PASSPORTS BACK, WHICH IS
NICE FOR THE OTHER IS HE DOESN'
WANT EVERYBODY TO DIE BECAUSE
THE NEXT ELECTION IS A BIG
PROBLEM.
MEET JIMMY, AREN'T F J.
>> ON THE ATKINS DIET.
I REALLY THINK THE BEST POINT
YOU MADE EARLIER WAS THE FACT
THAT TO A LOT OF THESE PEOPLE
WORLD PEACE IS IS AS IMPORTANT
AS STOPPING THE WRONG GUY FROM
DELIVERING IT.
REMEMBER, ONE OF THE OLDEST
JOKES IS ABOUT MAKING PEACE IN
THE MIDDLE EAST, THE ABRAHAM Mc
CORD DID THAT AND WE'RE
PRETENDING IT DIDN'T HAPPEN
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T MAKE FEES
WITH THE FACT THAT HE WAS THE
GUY TO DELIVER IT, BUT HOW CAN
YOU NOT LOOK AT THIS
MINISTRATION AND THINK WE NEED
HELP.
ANYONE WHO VOTED FOR KAMALA OWE
SARAH PALIN AN APOLOGY FOR
CALLING HER DUMB.
WHEN YOU SHOW UP TO THE
DEMILITARIZED ZONE IS THERE TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR WHO?
>> ADAM, DON'T YOU BELIEVE LIKE
ME THAT TRUMP IS OUR ONLY HOPE
IN SOLVING THESE ISSUES?
>> HE IS AN OUTSIDE THINKER,
HE'S ABSURD, IT'S ANOTHER MOVIE
TRUMP THE PLANT IS SO CRAZY IT
JUST MIGHT WORK.
JUST LIKE STRIPES BUT WITH THE
WINNEBAGO.
GIG LIKE HELL IF THEY GO OVER
THERE IN THE WINNEBAGO SOMEHOW.
I THINK RYDEN SHOULD ACCEPT
TRUMP'S HELP ON THIS, ON THE
ECONOMY, ON TAKING CARE OF CRIME
, WE COULD DO THIS BRITISH
MODEL WHERE JOE BIDEN IS OUR
FIGUREHEAD THAT LIVES AND A
CASTLE IN THEN TRUMP IS THERE
MAKING THE POLICIES.
THAT WOULD BE A FUNCTIONAL
SOLUTION.
TO GET THAT'S THE ONLY THING
THAT BIDEN CLAIMS HE COULD DO.
ALONGSIDE IS TO SEE WHO TRUMP
WILL PICK FOR THESE THINGS.
IT'S NEVER POLITICIANS.
ITS VELA CELEBRITIES.
I'M GOING TO GO OVER TO MOSCOW
WITH.
WE WILL STILL HEAR ABOUT COOLIO
AT THE BIDEN PRESS CONFERENCE.
SO CAT, IT IS KIND OF INCREDIBL
THAT UKRAINE IS AN ISSUE WHERE
THE REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS
ARE ON THE SAME PAGE WHICH IS
BILLIONS AND BILLIONS AND
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
THERE IS ALMOST NO DISSENT WITH
THE EXCEPTION OF A FEW PEOPLE,
RIGHT?
>> THEY'VE DONE A GOOD JOB, IF
YOU JUST SENT, YOU WOULD LIKE
PEOPLE TO DIE.
RATHER THAN RISK WINNING ON THI
MONEY AND THIS IS STILL GOING O
RIGHT YOU HAVE TO HAVE THE COST
BENEFIT ANALYSIS FOR EVERYTHING
NO MATTER WHAT IT IS.
THAT'S MORE IMPORTANT, THAT'S
ALL THEY HAVE AS TO BE LIKE OH,
TRUMP IS A HUGE THREAT.
THAT'S ALL THEY HAVE BECAUSE
EVERYTHING ELSE IS NOT GOING SO
WELL RIGHT NOW.
CONSIDER THIS, TRUMP CALLS OBAMA
, OBAMA CAN'T NOT THOUGHTS
THAT CALL AND THEN LET'S SAY
TRUMP CALLS HIM AND SAYS I HAVE
THIS PLAN, YOU AND I DO THIS
TOGETHER IF OBAMA SAYS NO, THEN
TRUMP CAN SAY I CALLED OBAMA AN
HE SAID NO.
>> PLUS, JOE WOULD HAVE NO IDEA
IT EVER HAPPENED.
>> I THINK WE DISSOLVED UKRAINE
BECAUSE ALL TRUMP HAS TO DO IS
CALL THE OBAMA SENATE THE OBAMA
SAY NO THEY LOOK TERRIBLE SO
THEY'RE GOING TO SAY YES IN THA
THEY JUST TELL BIDEN TO GO BACK
TO DELAWARE AND SLEEP FOR A FEW
DAYS.
HANG OUT WITH HUNTER.
GIG THINK THEY WILL RECEIVE THE
SAME WAY THEY RECEIVED AT
MARTHA'S VINEYARD.
>> V